.
JOINING US TO DISCUSS THE VERY
LATEST FROM UKRAINE, CNN
MILITARY ANALYST AND RETIRED
AIR FORCE COLONEL, CEDRIC
LEIGHTON.
COLONEL LEIGHTON, ALWAYS GOOD
TO HAVE YOU ON.
APPRECIATE HAVE YOU ON BRIGHTON
EARLY FOR US.
YOU SAID JUST WEEKS AGO, YOU
ARE CONCERNED ABOUT WEAPON
SHORTAGES IN UKRAINE.
CONGRESS JUST PASSED THIS NEW
DEFENSE BILL THAT INCLUDES $800
MILLION IN AID FOR UKRAINE.
IT ALLOWS THE U.S. GOVERNMENT
TO PAY IN INDUSTRY TO PRODUCE
WEAPONS, IT EXPEDITED DELIVERY
OF MUNITIONS AND REPLENISHES
U.S. WEAPONS STOCKPILES.
DOES THAT A GO FAR ENOUGH?
>> WELL, BORIS, GOOD MORNING.
I'M NOT SURE IT REALLY DOES.
BECAUSE WHAT WE'RE LOOKING AT
IS TIME.
YES, THE QUANTITIES SOUND
GREAT.
IT SOUNDS LIKE IT'S QUANTITY
ITSELF WILL BE AT LEAST
SOMEWHAT SUFFICIENT TO TAKE
CARE OF WITH UKRAINIANS NEED.
ESPECIALLY IF IT'S THE RIGHT
KIND OF WEAPONS.
BUT WE NEED TO ABSOLUTELY MAKE
SURE THAT THE BILL HAS
PROVISIONS IN IT THAT LOOK AT
THE SPEED IN WHICH THINGS ARE
DELIVERED AS WELL.
WE NEED TO MAKE ABSOLUTELY SURE
THAT THE WEAPON SYSTEMS ARE
EARMARKED FOR UKRAINE ACTUALLY
GET TO UKRAINE AND SEE THE
BATTLEFIELD SO THEY CAN BE
EFFECTIVE.
>> COLONEL, LET'S TALK ABOUT
THE PATRIOT SYSTEM --
CNN'S REPORTING THAT THE BIDEN
ADMINISTRATION IS FINALIZING
PLANS TO SEND IT TO UKRAINE.
HOW EXACTLY IS THIS GOING TO
HELP THE UKRAINIAN FORCES?
>> SO, I THINK BORIS, WHAT WE
NEED TO DO IS THINK ABOUT THE
AIR DEFENSE SYSTEM AS A SERIES
OF LAYERS.
UKRAINE HAS RIGHT NOW IS THE
FIRST TWO OR THREE LAYERS OF A
WORKABLE INTEGRATED AIR DEFENSE
SYSTEM.
THE PATRIOT MISSILE SYSTEM IS
DESIGNED TO PROVIDE THAT FOURTH
AND FINAL LAYER IN TERMS OF
ALTITUDE AND DISTANCE, THAT IT
CAN BE USED AT.
SO, THIS WOULD BE SOMETHING
LIKE DEVELOPING THE SYSTEM
SOMEWHAT SIMILAR TO WHAT THE
ISRAELIS HAVE WITH THE IRON
DOME.
AND WHAT IT DOES, IT USES THE
TECHNOLOGY OF THE PATRIOTS
SYSTEM PLUS THE TECHNOLOGIES OF
THE SYSTEMS THAT ARE ALREADY
THERE, TO GIVE THE UKRAINIANS A
MUCH BETTER CHANCE AT TAKING
OUT THE MISSILES THAT ARE
STREAKING THEIR TARGETS.
OF COURSE, IT ALSO WORKS
AGAINST DRONES AND MAYOR MANNED
AIRCRAFT THAT THEY NEEDED AS
WELL.
>> SO, WITH THIS FURTHER HELP
MOVE MOMENTUM TOWARDS UKRAINE
AT THIS POINT IN THE CONFLICT?
>> YES, I THINK IT WOULD.
BECAUSE WHAT THE PATRIOTS WOULD
DO IS IT WOULD ALLOW FOR THE
UKRAINIANS TO PROTECT MORE OF
THEIR TARGETS, MORE OF THE
AREAS AROUND KYIV, OR KHARKIV,
THE MAJOR CITIES, THE MILITARY
INSTALLATIONS.
OR THE CRITICAL INFRASTRUCTURE
AND WOULD ALLOW THEM TO TARGET
MORE OF THE INCOMING MISSILES.
THEY'VE DONE A GREAT JOB LIKE
ESTROGEN IS DULL STRIKES
INCLUDED 76 --
60 OF THEM WERE SHOT DOWN,
ACCORDING TO THE UKRAINIANS.
THAT'S A PRETTY GOOD TRACK
RECORD.
BUT THOSE 16 THEY GOT THROUGH
STILL GET A LOT OF DAMAGE.
AND YOU CAN GET THOSE REMAINING
16, THAT'S THE KIND OF THING
THAT WILL HELP THE UKRAINIANS,
AND WHAT YOU DO THAT, ONCE YOU
PROTECT THOSE TARGETED AREAS.
THEN IT MAKES IT MUCH HARDER
FOR THE RUSSIANS TO ACHIEVE
THEIR TACTICAL IN STRATEGIC
GOALS.
>> COLONEL LEIGHTON, WELL WE
HAVE, YOU THERE'S ANOTHER
ASPECT OF THAT MASSIVE DEFENSE
SPENDING BILL THAT I WANT TO
ASK YOU ABOUT.
IT INCLUDES AN END TO THE
MILITARY'S COVID VACCINE
MANDATE.
I'M WONDERING IF YOU THINK
ENDING THE MANDATE WAS THE
RIGHT MOVE.
>> IT'S NOT THE RIGHT MOVE,
BORIS.
AND HERE'S WHY.
THE VACCINE MANDATE BIG WE
SHOULD TAKE ALL THE POLITICS
OUT OF THIS.
WHAT IT IS IS A VERY CLEAR
READINESS ISSUE.
AND WHEN IT COMES TO VACCINES,
ALL OF US IN THE MILITARY HAVE
BEEN VACCINATED FOR ALL KINDS
OF THINGS, EVERYTHING FROM
MEASLES ALL THE WAY UP TO
ANTHRAX AND DEPENDING ON WHEN
YOU SERVED, YOU'VE GOT SPECIFIC
VACCINES FOR MALARIA, FOR OTHER
THINGS LIKE THAT.
SO, THESE VACCINES ARE NEEDED
IN ORDER TO KEEP THE MILITARY
AND ITS MOST EFFECTIVE.
WITH A VIRUS LIKE COVID-19, IT
NOT ONLY MUTATES, BUT IT
BECOMES PART OF THE PERMANENT
INFRASTRUCTURE OF DISEASES
AROUND THE WORLD, AND WHEN YOU
DEPLOY PEOPLE, IF THEY'RE NOT
IMMUNIZED AGAINST THESE
DISEASES, IT CAN RENDER THEM
MISSION INCAPABLE EMISSION
INEFFECTIVE.
AND THAT BECOMES A CRITICAL
READINESS ISSUE FOR THE U.S.
AND FRANKLY, FOR OUR ALLIES AS
WELL.
>> COLON